[Music]
a goal for 2022 is lowering the number
of traffic deaths i spoke with eric
palacios at eric palacios and associates
the sponsors of the next of this next
segment to learn more
eric happy new year hi rocky how are you
good to see you good to see you too it's
nice to have you back um of course we
talk about this a lot but it's so
important especially here in vegas
road safety
right what are you seeing right now into
2022.
uh unfortunately 2021 was one of the
deadliest years on record uh for
automobile and motorcycle accidents uh
we had over a 20 increase uh over 2020
to 2021 there was about 350 over 350
deaths
on our roadways that is so scary and how
many of those deaths were motorcycle
accidents
that's an interesting statistic as well
motorcycle accidents went up by almost
30 percent there were over 80 people
that died due to motorcycle accidents so
it's important to be real careful out
there and every time i see a motorcycle
on the road i'm just like i don't know
how they do it but you know to each his
own um you know how many or how can we
improve these numbers throughout the
community and just how can we help
people do better on the roads well
almost 50 of accidents are caused by
distracted drivers and most of those are
distracted by their cell phones so i
know um we are used to having our cell
phones 24 7 but it's very very important
that we put our cell phones aside while
we're driving if we absolutely must use
it make sure that it's with a hands-free
device but the best solution is to just
put the phone away during our 15-25
minute commute
nobody's going to die nothing's going to
happen we can answer our tax or answer
the phone as soon as we get home
the techs can wait right
exactly always great advice and
this this is a question a lot of people
have can we use our cell phones while
we're sitting at a red light
you know a lot of clients uh come to me
with tickets for uh using their cell
phone and that's their excuse i was at a
red light i wasn't moving right so it's
okay
it is still not allowed uh even if
you're sitting at a red light you cannot
use your phone unless it's with a
hands-free device so take this into
consideration and try not to use your
phone okay don't use your phone while
driving distracted driving but also most
importantly no drinking and driving
that's still a huge cause of many
injuries on the roads so of course if
you're going to be drinking uh choose a
designated driver or now with all the
ride share companies it's easy to get
home and not make that mistake
absolutely no excuses well thank you so
much eric this is such an important
reminder let's all have a healthy and
safe 2022. yes looking for way better
numbers during this year thank you
thank you
thanks to eric palacios and associates
for sponsoring that segment give them a
call at
website at eric 702-444-7777